all right this is a very very disturbing
clip I would encourage you maybe get the
kids out of the room before I play this
clip there is a guy named Alex Berenson
Alex Berenson has been consistently
wrong about just about everything
throughout the pandemic including
vaccines Alex Berenson was invited onto
the Tucker Carlson propaganda Fox News
show last night and Alex Berenson has
now made the principled and defiant
statement that the covid vaccines should
be pulled stop vaccinating everyone says
Alex Berenson and Tucker just nods along
he nods along like his head is on some
kind of uh swivel uh you have to see
this this is extraordinarily dangerous
and remember for context this is
business for Fox
just about everybody at Fox is
vaccinated
fox has a much stricter vaccine policy
than the one that Joe Biden attempted to
put in place which has been struck down
by the Supreme Court the fox policy is
even more strict this is a business
strategy for Fox News Let's Just Jump
Right In
uh it's we're at a very dangerous moment
Tucker and you know I I'm not
exaggerating I think this is probably
the most important appearance I've had
with you in the last two years
um it is it is completely clear now that
uh the vaccines don't really work at all
against Omicron
um in in these highly vaccinated and
highly boosted countries uh rates of
infection are incredibly high and rates
of serious disease and death are also
Rising the Israelis are predicting that
they're going to have more serious cases
than they ever had at the peak last year
um and the idea that we would solve this
with another booster is is just off the
charts insane I have not said this to
you before because I'm pretty careful
and I'm pretty careful with the data but
that's not true these vaccines these
mRNA vaccines the MRNA covered vaccines
need to be withdrawn from the market now
no one should get them pull them no one
should get boosted no one should get
double boosted they are a dangerous and
ineffective product at this point Point
against Omicron the spike that they make
your body make that you then produce
antibodies to is not the Omicron Spike
and earlier today Tony fauci said we're
not going to give people monoclonal
antibody products because the first
generation products because they don't
work against the Omicron Spike the same
logic applies to these mRNA vaccines and
giving people boosters even if in the
very short term it knocks down infection
rates there's a boomerang effect and
that's what they're seeing in all these
countries we're at a dangerous moment
and these products need to be withdrawn
pull them all cancel the vaccines now
just about every claim Barris and
Berenson makes is false but consider how
easily in just 80 Seconds he's able to
set so many fires and consider then how
difficult it is to put those fires out
particularly in in the minds of the fox
audience which is very receptive to this
stuff despite the fact that almost
everybody at Fox News is fully
vaccinated now as a reminder this clip
aside baronson has been wrong about just
about everything during the pandemic he
predicted the U.S would not have 500 000
kova deaths we're at almost 900 000
already
uh he argued that cloth and surgical
masks cannot protect you against the
coronavirus at all and of course they do
to varying degrees there's countless
peer-reviewed studies on this including
one called an Evidence review of face
masks against covid that's in the
journal pnas which I encourage you to
look at he he's been wrong on everything
he blamed vaccines for causing spikes in
severe illness when in reality the
vaccines prevent severe illness he
blamed the vaccines for suppressing
immune systems which is a total
misrepresentation of how the immune
system works he suggested countries like
Israel suffered from rolling out
vaccines early even though deaths in
hospitals hospitalizations in Israel
among the vaccinated were so low in that
initial period that he's talking about
so he's been wrong about everything
but now he makes these claims to Tucker
last night vaccines don't work at all
against Omicron that's not true we now
have extensive data the vaccines we
currently have are much less effective
at preventing infection from Omicron but
still very effective at preventing
hospitalization and preventing death
which is the point of vaccines he says
look at um or or he doesn't say but if
you look at the rates right now of
hospitalization and death stratified for
vaccination status it is not even close
with Omicron almost 100 percent of cases
in the United States he says there's
more cases in Israel than at the peak
last year well there's more cases in
most places right now than at their
previous Peaks because Omicron is so
contagious but there's still a
dramatically lower death rate up to 90
percent lower and that lower death rate
is particularly in the vaccinated
the data are extraordinarily clear he
says another booster won't solve this
well increasingly people aren't saying
take endless boosters of the same
vaccine in a couple months there will be
an Omicron calibrated vaccine he says no
one should get a vaccine at all the
evidence is clear you should get
vaccinated to lower your chance of
serious illness lower your chance of
ending up in the hospital and and a
lower your chance of ending up dead and
then he says it's this is a dangerous
product against Omicron there is no
evidence that the vaccines are dangerous
when used to fight Omicron and even what
that means is very squishy and imprecise
language this is a very dangerous guy
and Tucker has them on and he just nods
and he just nods and at this point it's
abundantly clear Tucker doesn't believe
this stuff it doesn't make what he's
doing any less pernicious in fact you
could argue it makes it more pernicious
because he knows that what this guy's
saying is untrue it doesn't matter in
the end because the decision is still
being made to put it on the air but it's
extraordinarily dangerous none of it is
based in evidence and we'll have the
clip if you're just listening today
we'll have that clip of Alex Berenson on
our Instagram which you can find at
David Pacman show you can also follow me
on Instagram at david.pakman I posted
yesterday a very very strange message
not exactly a love letter that I
received from a viewer you can find it
on my Instagram at david.pakman
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian eating a more
plant-based diet is a really great thing
to do for a number of different reasons
and our sponsor just egg is the
delicious plant-based egg you can use it
anywhere you use traditional eggs
because the taste and texture are
identical but just eggplant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs I use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelettes you can make
quiche frittata Crepes fried rice you
should see my fried rice recipe you can
really use it anywhere in baking or
anywhere you would use traditional eggs
when I first tried just egg I was
surprised that a plant-based egg could
both taste and cook just like
traditional eggs you can get it at the
grocery store instacart Amazon go try it
eating a more plant-based diet is a
great decision I do it and I'm not vegan
or vegetarian and just egg makes it that
much more easy and delicious